when you look at anything like a face
or a car
the perception of that thing is built up
from very basic filters and elements
that exist in the eye and elsewhere in
the brain that basically take the visual
scene around you and break it up into
dark lines and light lines
and moving things and the direction
they're moving
and then creates these
perceptions really that this best guess
about what's out there so since if i
draw two dots on a piece of paper and a
line right below it and i show it to you
you will get a slight sense that that's
a face
right but if i were to draw the line
vertical
in less so and if i were to draw the
line you know um
curved and off to the side you would
never think that was a face what that
tells us is that our perception of faces
is built up from these basic component
parts and indeed it is so there's this
kind of what's called a hierarchical
models and this is how we perceive
everything um
everything um so a song has its
component parts of tones and etc um
so when i look down the microscope you
know
there's an ability to for us to shrink
our perception into that narrow space
and time domain and to kind of get lost
in it but what's remarkable about the
human experience and actually what's
remarkable about being human
and we don't think other animals have
this although we don't know for sure
is that we can deliberately expand or
contract
our space and time perception i can make
the decision to be in this zoom and and
narrowly focused i can make the decision
to expand my thoughts i can um and you
know nowadays there are people talk a
lot about adhd and add some of which is
clinically valid attention deficit
disorders some of which is just kind of
being distracted we are having a harder
time nowadays because of the number of
things pulling us out of this what kind
of tunnel of focus that said i think
that human beings have evolved and
thrived on
largely on their basis of
people's willingness to stay in a narrow
aperture of experience so learning to
drive a race car and then to race at the
level that you have and to do other
things that you've done requires a
either a love of
and or a dedication to being in a pretty
narrow aperture set of experiences right
right into the light actually it's funny
i can talk about that but that's exactly
right
yeah and i think that inside of those
narrow apertures are
we create new milestones and rewards and
this gets it speaks to the kind of the
reward systems of the brain are pretty
generic um they relate to dopamine and
serotonin mainly mostly dopamine
dopamine is this incredible
neurochemical that makes us feel
motivated
and in a state of craving and drive well
you think about when you're in a narrow
aperture of say
pursuing a school degree or uh pursuing
uh a win in a race i mean it's as if
this system which is indeed very generic
dopamine you're now saying okay the
currency of reward is not the dollar or
the bitcoin or the euro it's dopamine
and i'm gonna
superimpose that
on to this narrow aperture of experience
now you finish that and then the you a
healthy person says um a healthy athlete
or student or physician whatever says um
okay now i'm gonna make the dopamine
about the healthy relationships of my
life or that my health my bodily health
the unhealthy entrepreneur
parent
athlete etc had can only derive dopamine
inside the narrow tunnel of that one
experience and
and in that sense it's very much like
true addiction um drugs like cocaine
amphetamine in particular but other
drugs as well
for some people alcohol but not
everybody
they create a dopamine loop whereby the
drug is the only thing that can really
give that intense dopamine release and
so the way i define addiction as opposed
to a healthy focused pursuit is
addiction is a progressive narrowing of
the things that bring you pleasure right
whereas being a healthy person means you
have
three four fifty a thousand things that
bring you pleasure so you're able to
take this very basic system and use it
for different things so um
all that said you know this narrowing of
aperture is fundamental to how we
arrived to be the dominant species on
the planet right we're in charge not the
house cats because somebody took the
time and really got excited about
building tools
um that house cats if they had the idea
in mind they actually never made it
happen uh so
it's you know these systems of focus
and expanding focus and shifting focus
and then the reward system which is
universally dopamine a few other
molecules also but mostly dopamine
that's been used over and over and over
again not just for 100 years or a
thousand years but probably for hundreds
of thousands if not millions of years
so is
dopamine the only driving force in
why we seek to accomplish something
um great question uh i would say it is
the primary driving force it's it's
supported by other
molecules so um we can
very clearly state
from a place of i think great confidence
that dopamine is
the molecule that is creating motivation
craving and drive for things that are
outside our immediate possession or
experience beyond the confines of our
skin so seeking new relationships
seeking a new uh item that you want to
buy seeking a degree seeking a win
seeking a trophy okay seeking but
there's another set of rewards that have
to do with the feelings of pleasure that
we derive from things that we already
have
um that we experience this very
intensely around um close relationships
with people or animals that we feel
kinship with and with great great
joy from their their mere presence right
you don't need to seek them they're just
there just feels good um the meal that
you're currently preparing and eating is
very different than the food you're
trying to hunt or go by to to to eat um
and the second reward system
is mainly governed by the molecule
serotonin it's more of a
of a calm sense of reward and i we can
say that because dopamine
the molecule dopamine is actually
biochemically converted into adrenaline
it actually is the thing from which
adrenaline is created and adrenaline is
what gives us energy to move not caloric
energy but neural energy to go pursue
things
serotonin is much more woven into the
systems of the brain and body that make
us feel not just willing but perfectly
content
to stay still
like ah it's really nice here i really
love this you know the feeling of this
person with enough serotonin
well and i think the two systems compete
and there's a and people are are you
know
skewed one way or the other somewhat um
there are skills and things that one can
do to learn to access these different
systems um
and there are other reward systems and
motivational systems too to
the so-called endogenous opioid system
we all can make these endogenous kind of
painkiller feel-good molecules these are
not the opioids of the opioid crisis
although the molecules are exactly the
same the opioid crisis is due to
companies making a synthetic version
of this soothing painkiller molecule and
then putting it in a pill that provides
it at very high dosages now that has
clinical uses like if you go in for a
surgery nowadays they'll prescribe
fentanyl almost
always but of course they can be abused
and they have they're highly addictive
because normally we don't experience
fentanyl levels of opioid circulating in
our body unless we've you know run a 100
mile race and we're trying to save our
family from famine or something perhaps
just as an adaptive mechanism but yeah i
would say that dopamine
is responsible for most of what humans
have accomplished and
and those who are able to access it i
have to you know presume that this is um
probably
what your experience has been i mean
that ability to set a goal a milestone
and work toward it oh man only driving
force literally that's when people ask
me why i what i love about racing i was
like setting a goal and achieving it
yeah well and dopamine's interesting
because
it obeys a very
simple set of rules which fall under the
umbrella what's called reward prediction
error and when you hear this it's sort
of a duh but we know this from literally
recordings from neurons using electrodes
or imaging
if you suddenly get
a surprise that you like dopamine is
massively released it gets you all
excited and motivated to pursue of what
you think preceded that okay finding i
don't know for a kid walking along the
street i don't know when i was a kid i
mean 100 bill would have been like whoa
like check this out there's a lot of
money um
if you are pursuing something or someone
or any kind of milestone and you don't
reach it
there what happens is dopamine actually
increases in anticipation of potential
rewards
not from the reward itself a lot of
people don't realize this and if you
don't get that let's say you are hell
bent on a gold medal not silver not
bronze
but platform gold medal and you end up
with a silver your baseline of dopamine
drops below
what it was prior to the pursuit
athletes know this right dude i've lived
this my whole i mean
am i screwed
no
you know cognitive the beautiful thing
about the dopamine system is that the
prefrontal cortex which is involved in
planning and decision making and
rationalization is also wired into the
system so one can say okay that was a
learning experience and i the rewards
came from
the fact that i didn't get bronze or
whatever we can reframe but
in the strictest sense that's the way
dopamine reward prediction error works
now the other thing is also true which
is that
if we are in pursuit of something
and then we achieve it
there's a positive feedback loop
whereby the brain
and nervous system
better remembers all the steps that led
to that successful completion of the
milestone
so this is wired into the soul excuse me
into so-called neuroplasticity which is
our ability to change and so you start
thinking about how success breeds
success
yeah that's all about dopamine oh wow
you started thinking about how failure
make you know people start creating this
narrative especially in depressive
states of like
it's just not worth trying anymore in
some ways they're protecting they're
subconsciously protecting the dopamine
they still have
and
and i was fascinated to learn that
recently there have been studies showing
that
people who have chronic pain
the pain itself actually starts becoming
wired into this dopamine system it's
very interesting you know there are
these people who um are always talking
about their pain sure always talking
about it's almost like gosh like for
somebody who's not in chronic pain that
can be very perplexing and sometimes
even annoying and like gosh this person
like all i hear about is the hard
relationship the heart the pain
but in any case that
that system can start becoming its own
reward
mechanism whereby the thinking about the
pain actually starts to trigger dopamine
release and so this is a rather this is
a adaptive
circuit so there's a lot of dimensions
that this could go but for somebody
who's very driven who wants to be the
best who has a milestone i would say two
cautionary notes one first first of all
that's beautiful and that's wonderful
and that's a lot of what makes life rich
two
one needs to make sure that along the
way
you are registering the wins the the
milestones
some closer horizon milestones yeah yep
and then the third is that
the schedule of reward that works best
for keeping people in a healthy state of
mind of pursuit
is one of the same one that the casinos
use
to extract money from you which is
random intermittent reward here's what i
mean the slot machine it does it's not
every 10 pulls that keeps people playing
a win every 10 pulls it's the randomness
of it right as soon as you're ready to
walk away you get a win and then it
keeps people going
this we can apply this in our own lives
that in this especially true with kids
it's great to reward your wins
but every once in a while
take that gold medal
and just say don't say it wasn't good
enough but just
go right back into living life and
pursuing new
new pursuits what what i've seen over
and over again is that people that are
very driven
become so attached to this dopamine
reward system
that they get the rew
they reach the milestone excuse me and
then
they feel depressed well why because
dopamine is released by pursuit
motivation and craving not by
reaching the reward itself so the
journey being the destination is a is a
dope again a dopaminergic as we say
phenomenon
so it's important to have goals perhaps
very lofty goals the long-term ones so
that you stay in the pursuit for longer
but then like you said you need the
incremental goals to
stay satisfied essentially and correct
and and to keep you
driven
so dopamine
there's a beautiful experiment that
illustrates this has been done in
animals and and just by way of natural
circumstances in humans let's talk about
the animal experiment um because it's
simple you take two rats separate cages
um rats like food and they'll lever
press for
a piece of chocolate or something tasty
especially um they can achieve pleasure
now you take those rats and you put them
behind a little wall where they have to
do some work like climb over the wall to
get the lever both of them will do that
now you take one of those rats and again
this was done with humans as well and
you deplete its dopamine
you put them in right in front of the
lever both of them will sit there and
eat the food dope dopamine is not
required to experience pleasure
but now
if you remove the wall but you put the
rats just one rat length away from the
lever what you'll notice is the one that
has dopamine because it's a normal rat
will walk towards the lever press it and
get the food
the rat or person who does not have
dopamine won't even move one body length
away to reach pleasure
so the key takeaway here
whether or not you're a highly driven
person or not is that
rewards achieved without prior effort
don't tap into the dopamine system
and they basically will [ __ ] an
organism or human
at the level of the mind
such that you can't
really experience pleasure the same way
[Music]